- Depending on which science
fiction you want to reference,
the researchers here at the
University of Konstanz in Germany
have either built a
holodeck from "Star Trek,"
or "The Matrix,"
or something kind of like
the old alien abductions
from "The X-Files."
It's just that they've
built it for locusts.
- One of the great challenges
in studying collective behavior
is that there's this intricate
network of interactions
among the individuals that
we can't see, we can't control.
And so, it's really
difficult to understand
how these locusts, with
their local interactions,
can scale up to swarms
that can extend across
hundreds of square kilometers.
We thought, "What if we
could have individuals
"moving and interacting
with virtual swarms?"
And so, that's why we've
designed this setup.
What we do is we put the animal
on this large, motion-compensating sphere.
As the animal moves,
the sphere always moves to keep it on top
and so, it can move in a
never-ending desert environment.
And by tracking that movement,
we know where the animal's gone.
The locusts believe
these virtual individuals
to be other locusts.
They will tend to align
their direction of travel
with near individuals.
They will think of themselves
as being within a real swarm.
- Locusts don't have depth perception
in the way that humans do.
Prey animals generally have
eyes on each side of their head,
trading off 3D vision for
a much wider field of view.
So there's no need for
sci-fi holographic systems
or tiny little 3D glasses here.
As long as they keep an exact track
on the locust's eye position
and update the screen fast enough,
it seems to fool them.
I'll be honest, I do find
this a little bit unsettling...
...and it's only going to get
more unsettling from here.
- Ultimately, decision-making is made
in the brain of the animal.
So if we're to understand
these vast swarms,
we actually need to go in
and look at how the brain
processes this information.
So in this VR,
we're basically plugging
into the spinal cord.
The animal here is tethered.
It has to be held in place
but can still walk freely
on a ball that's elevated by air,
so it doesn't have friction,
allowing the locust, again,
to move and interact with a virtual swarm.
So, we know what the
animal's responding to
but now we can also
decode the neural signals
that are underlying the
decisions it's making.
So, locusts impact the livelihood
of 1 in 10 people on the
planet through food shortage.
They contribute to humanitarian
crises across the globe,
yet no one understood
why they form swarms.
- So, the researchers here
have also commissioned
this massive imaging hangar
and they're going to track
thousands of locusts individually
by attaching tiny
retroreflective tags to each one
and using a motion-capture
system with more than 30 cameras.
Sub-millimeter precision,
100 frames a second.
Again, I had questions,
starting with: where do you
order thousands of locusts from?
- Well, luckily for us,
it turns out that
entomophagy or eating insects
is becoming an important
aspect for humans
and also for agriculture,
for farm animals,
so there are actually huge
locust breeding centers.
We collaborate with them and so,
they bred the insects for us.
We have a whole team of
experienced individuals(!)
from senior professors to
undergraduate students,
all working together,
gluing these little
tags on the individuals.
And this allows us to see the
three-dimensional information
much, much more easily
than we could using
many video cameras.
The imaging hangar is
15 by 15 by 8 meters.
It's designed to mimic the environment
in which locusts have evolved.
We have extremely bright lights
that capture the natural wavelength
of light that they experience.
We have the correct temperature of
around 27, 28°C within this large space.
So first, we're looking at the locusts
in different densities
to see which different
structures and patterns form,
but then, we also want to understand
how these voracious insects
eat their way through crops.
And also, how they avoid
predators when doing so,
so we're also startling the individuals
to see how social behavior
also influences their
response to predators.
When the insects hatch,
they're flightless.
In fact, they're flightless for the
first two months of their lives.
It's only in the final adult stage
that they take to the wing.
And so, the critical stage
for understanding the swarms
and also controlling them
is these flightless juveniles.
- And this is about 10,000 locusts.
There are questions about
testing on insects, of course,
but the consensus right
now is that...
they're insects.
And as long as there's
no unnecessary harm caused,
the trade-off is well worth it.
These would've been ground up
for animal feed, after all,
and the world doesn't have
a problem with that.
And locust swarms aren't cooperative.
Researchers have discovered
that locusts march in formation
because traveling in the
same direction at the same speed
is the easiest way for each individual
to avoid being eaten by other locusts.
If humans can understand
this swarm's behavior,
maybe we can start to understand
the gigantic, devastating swarms
with billions or even trillions
of locusts,
the ones that destroy food supplies.
Or maybe we can start to
improve the forecasting tools,
because right now, the
only methods the world has
to deal with devastating
locust plagues
are vast amounts of
industrial pesticides...
and hope.
- I find it astonishing that
there are pest insects
that impact so many
people on the planet,
and yet there's so little
research into this.
And one of the main reasons
is that the people that really are
impacted by locusts,
they're subsistence farmers.
They can't afford agrochemicals.
You also have countries
where they've got other
problems to deal with,
such as internal strife and conflicts.
The last experiments
we did with locusts,
when I was based in Oxford,
we had, I think, the most
was 110 individuals.
To approximate what
they're doing in nature,
we need to start looking at
tens of thousands of individuals.
The key here
is that we need these very
large-scale experiments
to be that bridge between
the lab and the wild.
One of the amazing things about locusts
is that the swarms just
suddenly appear out of nowhere.
And so, what we're trying to mimic here is:
as population density increases,
we think that these swarms
will suddenly emerge.
They'll suddenly start
marching together in unison.
We're just beginning to understand
the wonders of collectives,
how groups of neurons
communicate with each other
to allow animals to make decisions,
and then, how social interactions
connect brains together
such as in locust swarms.
So, we think locusts can
sense the environment
through this communication
within the swarm.
This gives them a
swarm intelligence
that's beyond the brain
of any individual.
We can use this to
begin to understand
how and why these swarms form
and therefore,
how we can best minimize
the impact on humans.
- It's a couple of hours later.
The imaging hangar
has been blocked off
from all humans
for a while,
and the researchers here are
now seeing marching behavior
that has never been
observed in the lab before.
It's only ever been in the wild.
It's working,
and they've come up
with like a dozen ideas
for new experiments in
the last 10 minutes.
This is brilliant.